this morning on the dish chicago native
and acclaimed chef eric williams after
honing his skills for more than two
decades in chicago's fine dining scene
williams opened his own space three
years ago in hyde park his restaurant
virtue is southern based food with a
side of what might best be described as
his great grandmother's hospitality and
william's words making everyone in the
room feel special
walleyes too 130. virtue restaurant is
as much a reflection of its diverse and
historic hyde park neighborhood
cornbread shared cornbread share as it
is its name virtue by its very
definition is high moral standard if
it's anything i can do to help let me
know the standard is kindness the
standard is taking care of people the
standard is treating people the way you
want to be treated i appreciate that
well thanks for your support that's a
pretty sick stove the first solo
endeavor for executive chef and owner
eric williams fire gumbo green tomato
gumbo green tomato it is also a
reflection of him look we're
unapologetically black i can't be
anything else it is definitely who i am
and it is definitely how i'm cooking
however
i'm recognized as a chef
not as a black chef first as a chef
professional first that happens to be
black
and so inflections of who i am
should be identifiable in the food that
i cook i need that collard green now
ma'am at virtue that means southern
cuisine
like chicken and andouille sausage gumbo
with carolina gold rice which creates a
really really interesting texture
because it doesn't cook in 10 minutes
and it actually has texture and
nutrients
braised short ribs with creamed spinach
and crushed potatoes
on your right is a little bit of our gem
lettuce salad with kind of a interesting
ingredient we took black eyed peas and
made them the croutons so they're fried
black eyed peas on the salad
but as a chef who's trained in italian
and french cooking
williams sees even more
there are so many things that show up in
southern food that people identify as
southern food but don't really think
about the history or how that may have
come about what we want to do is we want
to think about how food can be delicious
how it can be progressive but how it
also preserves the flavor profiles of
the south without everything coming
immediately out of the fryer like the
blackened catfish with carolina gold
rice and barbecue carrots this is
wonderful the seasoning on this it's
like a little kick oh it definitely has
a little bit of spice there's blackening
spice on the catfish and that's what
lends to that flavor oh my gosh
and for dessert
millie's banana pudding
chef becky pandola
her grandmother made phenomenal
banana pudding and it's a very nostalgic
space for her
so
this is a labor of love um so becky
makes the best the same can be said for
the entire restaurant there are a lot of
things that go into it to be perfectly
honest like the idea that i grew up in a
home where the china was kept in a china
cabinet but we never ate on it and at
this point in my life i really want to
eat on the china from the chins pattern
on that china to homey touches like an
array of pillows everything throughout
virtue is a part of the experience these
are holes that have been reclaimed from
fire trucks that were used to break
riots
or as they were called protests against
black people during the civil rights
movement the artwork in the restaurant
helped set the tone that is the first
piece that was hung
woven throughout the space it is all by
african-american artists why is it so
important to have a space like this as
you mentioned it's it's the food it's
the culture it's the ownership it's the
art on the wall it's every aspect of it
because in the past we've seen
a lot of other cultures take agency of a
culture that's not theirs at some point
when do we take agency of our own
culture and of our own space and so we
want to
continue to not just polarize what seoul
means to us and what southern means to
us but we want to celebrate it
williams grew up on the west side of
chicago a rough or what he calls
challenging neighborhood it was in river
north at chicago's famed restaurant mk
where he built his career
over two decades williams worked his way
up from salad station to celebrated chef
and partner you should get paid twice
when you're at work you should you
should get paid your check
and then you should get paid through
education and i had a really really
thorough education in that space when mk
closed williams brought some of the
philosophies behind it to virtue like
passing on that education so we're going
to do
black and catfish serving as a mentor as
part of embark chicago a program that
provides experience experience-based
learning opportunities to low-income
high school students okay put this down
and lay away i've been in
under-resourced communities
my entire life and so i know what it
feels like to
witness and and be privy to resources
and i know what it feels like to be
without we just take a very practical
approach
teaching life skills in you know our
everyday practice and showing the
parallels or the life application as to
how those things relate there you go
virtue
in name and practice let me know when
you want to work the fifth station
i got a spot for you
there's not a team member here that we
wouldn't extend ourselves for
that we didn't
make an attempt to extend ourselves for
during the pandemic
and every manager and or partner that's
a part of this establishment are people
that i have relationships with that grew
out of our experience in the restaurant
and that continue to flourish as a
result of the philosophy of taking care
of one another you know
i'd be remiss if i didn't say right
we're still in a pandemic
we still have challenges that we have to
face in the world we're glad that people
can create nostalgic moments
um in a place that that is beginning to
feel very very nostalgic to us
and a place that has a signature drink
that is patience is a virtue so cheers
to eric williams who's done a remarkable
job with the campaign
cheers and i want to say it really is
touches everywhere including
signs that are up throughout i have this
sweatshirt because it was so struck by
it but reminding you of all the things
that virtue is and you really do see it
throughout the space in the artwork you
walk in there and you just feel like
you've stepped into someone's home and
it's so beautifully done yes every
aspect of it and delicious i can't wait
to check this place out the next time in
chicago and can i just say the first
time brian applegate's been in my ear
saying drink first
drink first drink don't talk just drink
is with the instructions right for the
record and can i quickly say i'm in the
control room eric williams also by the
way not just virtue within but within
the community has done so much work
there and is such a big part of it we
only showed a small part of it